there's a new thing going around the
internet they caught my eye it's a meme
called okay boomer you heard about this
yeah it's a meme that makes the boomer
generation look out of touch here's an
example take a look woman uses the
camera correctly yeah yeah okay so you
see someone doing something kind of lame
and being labeled a boomer and it's it's
really caught fire it's it's really I
tell you being a boomer must be hell I
mean thank God I missed the cutoff by
two years oh cool yeah ya know yeah I
mean you know me too so wait wait a
minute you're three years older than me
you're a boomer no no I'm not no no I'm
not a I'm not a boomer I swear I am NOT
a Boomer
oh yeah we'll improve it by subjecting
yourself to the boomer Inquisition
whatever Inquisition what is this you
are hereby summoned by representatives
of the Cabal of generations me a gen Xer
a millennial and a Jen's ear first
question what is your favorite Billy
Eilish song oh but it's hard to pick I
mean I love all his music so much so
wrong it's bad guy oh come on next
question what's the first step when
applying for a mortgage oh well first
need to get your credit pre-qualified I
mean wait a minute I don't know I'm
renting
I don't know I'm renting
all right what's the first thing you do
when you log on to Facebook check all my
friends status updates wrong no one uses
Facebook anymore it's all about the grin
these days damn it when you text someone
smdh what does it mean starting my damn
Honda what's your Harry Potter house
mid-century craftsman I'm not a boomer
I'm not give me one more chance
fine one final test eat this
avocado toast sure yeah I'll Vacarro
toast I mean that's a fantastic I love
it now ya understand the concept
complete me I I love avocado toast and I
I don't quite know where you bite into
it where do you bite it
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]